you are in this race get in the fight
yourself
what we're gonna do what we're gonna do
shut up I'm not missing my race car
yes you're not going to jail
oh crap
listen son you think you're gonna play a
stupid video game about cars and you're
gonna become a Race Car Driver
all I ever wanted to do is be a racer
I'm doing it
the 10 of you are the best
Gran Turismo players in the world now is
your chance to race real cars it's not
gonna work the guys who race are Elite
athletes your kids are scrawny little
gamer kids that's where you come in
do you think you can do the impossible
I'm here to prove that you can't you get
tired
I know what I'm doing not a face I've
raced this track a thousand times in the
game let me drive it my way
that was actually pretty great
we have a newcomer this year his
presence is shaking the foundation of
the sport this is the major leagues the
other driver your pit crew are going to
hate you it's much easier with a
joystick isn't it
I can't see anything
I'm not sure if I can do this most
people can't
I got a feeling you're not most people
[Music]
Grace
so I'm not gonna quit
gonna prove to everyone
though you belong
you've raised it what like a thousand
times now you just got to do it in real
life
Gran Turismo based on a true story